oh my god look at this bad the future
we're zooming who's zooming who we're
zooming you
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith
i am mark bernardin hey uh-huh
if you're wondering why we look like
this uh it's because i went to chicago
this weekend for uh the movies pop-up
oh grand opening and and jay and i did a
show in mchenry
um and uh since i i got home just this
morning
um you know i came from a covert hot
spot so
we felt it would be responsible to not
have me in the same room with
you know a guy who's got a family and
another guy who's starting a family
and carrying those illinois covet germs
with me so here we are
zooming it man but uh it's the night
before
the election folks we've all got
electile dysfunction we're not going to
talk about that
because we're going to spend the next
three months talking about that probably
tonight next three weeks no doubt
tonight
we're gonna talk about all the [ __ ] that
uh truly matters man
so uh what do you got uh you know i'm
trying to think what i did this past
week
um i started a new job that i can't say
very much of anything about
um no i was actually looking forward to
i saw your tweet
yeah this week or this weekend or
something i was like oh [ __ ] i want to
ask you about it
and uh skype dance sky interactive or
skydance new media
um has engaged me and a couple of other
um wonderful things i'm talking about
i can talk a little bit about it
you know which at this point right now
deeper than anything else i can talk
about and it'll be scant of details at
best
but um but i'm in a writer's room um
for a new project uh joining me in that
room are a couple of people who've been
on the podcast before
i'm todd stashwick who's a co-host on
black man beyond evan narcisse who was
part of a black panther round table we
did
um way back when um janina gavin carr
who's
uh never been on the podcast but as a
lovely woman and nerd
royalty um and then and then a couple of
other folks and and
it's so far we've been doing it for
about two weeks and it's
it's inspiring in good ways and it's
interesting to do
a new thing you know hey man
what and what's the idea um
the idea is for uh a project that
probably won't
hit uh whatever it's going to hit for
another
year and a half two years maybe um
but but i i promise you
it'll be familiar while also being
totally new and interesting and
different
me and shecky have guesses but we're not
gonna do that to you
you're not gonna make it i'll talk you
off the air about it
there you go and find out if i'm right
um that's exciting
so wait so how many jobs do you have
right now um
right now this is the only job well now
i was going to say some of you that's
paying me but that's also not true
um but one two
three three jobs
that are currently in motion um and then
still
waiting to hear on a couple of other
things that are you know as i keep on
having to to remind my mother
um this is a business of irons and fires
and the only way to keep it going is to
have as many as you can possibly have
going
at the same time and maybe one will
spark
maybe two will spark if you're lucky and
if three
or four start to go you're just spinning
plates
you just spin them plates man one of
them stops then you give it your
attention
and and then if another one stops at the
same time then you're doing this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you used to see on the old like [ __ ]
tonight show
awesome man an embarrassment of of
riches nice to have
work while all this is going on indeed
ver very nice to be
active especially now um
you know eight there's a covid b the
world is doing any number of things
um so to to find distraction that
isn't just you know i guess i'm gonna
watch all of new girl again
or who you know would be great to do
let's watch her every friday the 13th
i watched you know what i've been
watching this remember we were talking
about the vow
and like the vow
was totally like worth a watch but very
paced and boy they pulled the taffy
they got this nexium doctor doing over
on stars
with india oxenberg
this is the one man they they distill
that [ __ ] down to the pure concentrate
and they tell you [ __ ] that you didn't
hear
in the other one like you know you start
to hear you start to go
like if you watch the vow you're like
yeah he's a
you know bastard this guy but like 120
years for what
when you watch the stars documentary
you're like
oh yeah now i understand why they gave
him 120 [ __ ] years like
the the vow kind of like
it certainly didn't clean him up but i
mean it didn't give you
all the [ __ ] dirt that the one on
stars is giving and [ __ ] like that
and i find like i did not watch
smallville
but i am like oddly like dialed in to
the allison
mack of it all like because she's a bit
bigger
in the story and she was in smallville
right she played
oh yeah for a long time i think for the
entire duration of the run
um she it's just so
fascinating to watch like just like the
vow
you know as you're watching this it's
very easy to judge where you're like
how the [ __ ] who gets fooled by this
[ __ ] and blah blah blah
but it is like a page turner man and and
they are getting the
the job done in like half the time that
the valve got the job done
um but what hbo's got that i've been
digging is um did you watch the nicole
kidman thing the undoing
yeah i did i saw the first episode i
haven't seen the second like [ __ ]
rich white people
it's crazy like as it starts you're just
like good lord is this just about
opulence and living on the upper west
side like
this is kind of gross and then finally
like the plot kicks in sooner right
um but that's been worth watching and i
and also
like hbo is good at putting together a
spot or a trailer where you're like i
think i know what this is all about
and then you're watching the show and
you're like i have no idea this is what
i
didn't know this was going there yeah
this is [ __ ] pretty damn interesting
so um i've watched that that's pretty
good and when i was i mean this is an
old suggestion but
i was since i was in chicago
i re-watched the blues brothers for the
first time in a long time
[ __ ] works man it really holds up
like oddly enough like it was a good
time and watching it in chicago
really added something to it you got to
realize like at one point
uh movies is at this place called st
lou's assembly and it's
it's there until friday so people could
still go me and jay are just gone
so um st louis assembly is right in the
loop
like which is like you know where the
train comes around and stuff that helps
rain
yeah like any art it's so crazy like we
were standing outside of movies
like taking pictures and stuff and then
the l train would go by
and like to me that is like
that's that's movies you know what i'm
saying like that was how i first
interacted with chicago through movies
like oh they got that
l train you know what i'm saying like
it's it's so strange so
people in chicago are used to the l
train or elevated train and [ __ ] they're
used to you know
[ __ ] so used to it they don't think
about it but
like we don't have that i didn't have
that in jersey we don't have it here i
know they have them in new york but like
i was just so oddly fascinated by and
then every time the train would go by
like i felt like oh my god we're in a
movie and then i turned around and we
were like oh my god
movies is from a movie like the whole
[ __ ] weekend
just felt unreal man like crazy
movie set and i was hoping that i catch
a little bit of the [ __ ] batman
action because they're shooting right
out there in chicago and on friday night
i was gonna [ __ ] like
tweet out to matt reeves and be like
where are you shooting that movie man
can i please come bomb the set
but they're done shooting oh no yeah all
their chicago stuff apparently or at
least the outdoor stuff
is all wrapped up so i didn't get to see
any batman be done but i talked to some
people
like i saw some batman the other night
um but uh that that that was my
that was my weekend what did you do this
weekend um
this weekend let's see i watched
for the first time because i am i am a a
notorious and
avowed wussy when it comes to horror and
so it's halloween and i'm like you know
what i
want to watch something scary ish um but
i also want to watch something i've
never seen before
and so i've never seen john carpenter's
original halloween
what never did so on halloween night i
sat down and i watched halloween for the
first time
how did you skate this long without
[ __ ] seeing halloween
you know it's it's the one that got away
like i saw
no not that it got away not like i
couldn't get it back any time i wanted
it
but i've seen friend of 13th i saw
nightmare on elm street i've seen the
exorcist
you know like i've done a lot of that
sort of classic
sort of 70s 80s horror i still haven't
seen
um a texas chainsaw massacre i feel like
i ought to watch that
um just to know
yes yes you should my kid
my kid just watched it like the other
week because their her and her boyfriend
are in dallas and
shooting her tv show and she's like we
watched the texas chainsaw massacre
and i was like that's the clerks of
horror movies and then she [ __ ] uh
referenced something else and she was
like we might watch citizen kane and i
was like
that's the clerks of good movies
and she was like not everything could be
the [ __ ]
it clerks of the rosetta stone to kevin
yes pretty much
you put it in ever seen halloween two or
three you've never seen a halloween
picture of your life
um i think i might have seen um no
freddy's the
no jason goes to space i saw that jason
goes to space one
um i feel like i probably saw bits of
like halloween h2o
when it came out but uh that that is not
it's not my genre and not my jam what
was your so what's your
late in life take on [ __ ] what's your
hot tape
you're like a scary movie kids i don't
know if you've ever heard of this
picture
reporting from the front marker
[Laughter]
what was your take up um i think it's a
it's a very well-made movie
um with you know in the way and one of
the king of the independent films like
he made that movie for peanuts just like
texas chainsaw massacre toby hooper all
those cats maybe i think toby hoopers
was even cheaper
but like both of those are two of the
most successful independent films of all
time
far more [ __ ] successful than like
clerks el mariachi
[ __ ] reservoir dogs [ __ ]
brothers like those movies made [ __ ]
bank and cost nothing and still earned
to this day
yeah you know and so it's it is as as
everything that's you know 30 40 years
old
you know it's dated in ways that you
know don't
help it you know and i watch it with my
son who's 16 and
yeah not to say that he was bored by it
but there's vast stretches of that movie
where not very much happens
yeah um because it's doing like the sort
of the work of all right let's tell you
who laurie strode is let's
build this world let's show you the
dumbass teenage horndogs that she hangs
out with let's
unspool the story of michael myers but
not very
well to a certain degree like what's he
do we don't know he's evil incarnate why
it seems like he just killed you know
i'm sorry
in the second one they made it make more
sense because i don't think they do this
in the first one
but spoilers they're related
lori and michael myers and laurie strode
are related but i don't they didn't
reveal that in the first one right
now that happened in halloween too which
john carpenter
didn't direct uh but i think he had a
hand in the screenplay if he
maybe wrote the screenplay but um the
idea was
he's come back because that's the
remaining
sibling right so he keeps trying to kill
her
and they've retconned that out
like what's his name [ __ ]
[ __ ] was that
there's a noise over there but the dogs
over there
that's [ __ ] up anyway
um they rec conned it out because you
know they made those uh the sequel
with uh jamie lee curtis and then they
made another one but they're holding it
till next year
right those movies they don't
acknowledge halloween two
or any of the it's just a direct sequel
to the first one
to rex equals the first one which i
that's why i didn't
engage with the new one because i'm not
like
i wouldn't say i'm a purist but my you
know for the same reason that honestly i
never really got into much of the new 52
ec because i'm like well my story my
stories were the old stories and now
they've just kind of stopped telling
those stories
so my halloween is like no man [ __ ]
michael myers is that that's her brother
so i didn't really go for the i didn't i
still haven't seen the new
for that reason because i felt like oh
man don't do that don't like get rid of
the continuity i like that continuity
yeah like it's it's a very well-made
low-budget horror movie that does
kind of what you want it to do and it
you know not even to say that it plays
by the rules because it makes up a
decent chunk of those rules as it's
going
yes um and don't forget also you're
seeing it through
like you know the prism of 2020 that's a
movie that invented most of those rules
as well totally like all the the whole
like you know the virgin [ __ ] dichotomy
and
like well you know laurie strode is
going to survive because she's the final
girl and the final girl has to be pure
she's the very first final girl almost
to some degree yeah
yeah you know and and like it and it's
it's always a hoot to go back and watch
those old movies and watch them invent
the language that we use today which has
been
you know refined in in at times and and
honed in places but it's still kind of
raw and
elemental in that movie and yeah like
michael myers is a legit scary figure
they they they play a lot of you know
he's standing by the bush and now he's
not he's across the street and now he's
not
um the kills are a little bit slow too
like he's a slow zombie yeah one of the
first like
real stalker slashers i got time i'll
get there
that's right i'm inevitable he's the
thanos of uh
of [ __ ] serial killers it built him
up too i mean it
it it'd probably be easy for you to
appreciate because you've seen many
movies at this point
over the course of your life but i
watched those movies as they were
happening in real time
and they turned michael myers into like
a cult
figure you know i don't you could argue
that he never broke as big as
jason and freddie so to speak um but
like
i loved the [ __ ] you know the the
shape that's what they call them in the
first one
um and then as the story kept going on
like how donald pleasance adds more and
more to the like there's a beautiful
monologue he gives in the halloween too
about like [ __ ] how he's evil
incarnating [ __ ] like that i i go for
those movies in such a big bad way
is that [ __ ]
i think there's a squirrel looking at me
[Laughter]
and i think he's like like because it's
nighttime out no [ __ ] squirrel should
be there
but this guy's looking out the window
like intrigued because i got the ring
light on
caught his attention he's just like
like oh you got some trick or treats in
there you weren't even left i would much
prefer to be stared at by brett deacon
than this [ __ ]
um we are uh of the uh
we're home doing a show which i was
[ __ ] like delighted a box i was like
i'm gonna smoke weed and then i was
reminded of course
that on facebook that sort of thing is
frowned upon could get you tossed off
oh really which sounds sexier than i
mean it yeah you can [ __ ] lie about
politics on facebook
don't you [ __ ] smoke uh youtube i
don't think has the same issues
but i speaking of issues uh you know i'm
a [ __ ] weed addict so i've got issues
with my own so
anytime you see mr miracle pop up
that's just to block that's you know
that's me
going hey kids read mr miracle
and nothing will be going on behind this
book
of course not no yeah pay attention over
here
nothing happening over there uh do we
have news to give people
we we do um there's one other thing i
watched this weekend that i
told you tell me but i'm curious if you
watched um the new season of
um my next guest needs no introduction
david letterman's
talk show on netflix no who what
interview did you zero in on
he uh i saw two of them i saw robert
downey jr
um which was interesting but not overly
deep you know like like robert is it is
as you know incredibly charming and so
just watching him be like robert downey
jr is always fun and
hanging out on his motherboard it's like
getting a free marvel movie for heaven's
sakes
kind of you know the armor yeah and you
know and he talks you know a bit about
marvel and and you know he
he doesn't think that that he'll do it
again
he thinks that you know tony stark is in
his rearview mirror and there's other
exciting things that he's trying to
chase down we'll see
you know when they when they throw him a
thousand cadillacs like hey man would
you
reconsider oh this guy likes to fill
with gold is that okay for you
i mean but let's be honest look i want
it i want them to give
him [ __ ] a thousand cadillacs filled
with gold but do they even need him
at this point i guess no after the next
three movies right
right think about it the first one
coming out is black widow and from what
we understand he might have a little
something in it people have rumored or
whatnot
after that it's the eternals and that's
like meant to set up a whole new [ __ ]
lineup of stories
but then right after that is going to be
spider-man 3
which is going to make people forget
about [ __ ] avengers because it's
become
avengers [ __ ] five practically with
all the characters that they're adding
in doctor strange and
everything else and what sounds like
this sinister six
so it feels like you know especially in
a world where they're like doctor
strange is
now gonna be peter's mentor you know it
feels like
they're like we're good like you know
what i'm saying like because
he's as wonderful as he is he's you know
pricey
but i don't even think price is the
thing anymore i think they're
they're so hell-bent on making like
phase after phase and as we could see
from the new phase coming
it's not everyone we've spent the last
10 years watching it's like ladies and
gentlemen
here are the new kids and so in order
for that to have any impact or land or
for them to start building their own
um series their own decade of movies i
guess
like you know as much as it sucks for
everyone who loves them as a character
me included
for storytelling it makes sense to kind
of
yeah go like this like you know i
perhaps if they brought them back let's
say they backed up
[ __ ] a hundred cadillacs filled with
gold news i gotta [ __ ] it let's do it
imagine how devastating it would be if
it was like oh
i wish i wish he'd stayed dead that was
you know
so i i don't i i have mixed feelings
about it
like you know if unless if if
if robert downey jr and kevin foggy both
came out together and they were like you
know what we've got like five more
iron man stories i'm in but
i i don't see that happening i think
they're
they're like you know look man we got we
got to set up
uh shang shang chi
like we gotta set up miss marvel we
gotta set
like you know they're expanding the
universe rather than going like let's do
our greatest hits
i think we're like why would we kev
smith it like clerks happen
we're gonna kick knoll in it we're just
gonna keep making movies and never look
back which i guess makes sense
yeah i mean i i think there there is
there is the version of
like yes tony stark's story is done like
we've told that entire arc
beginning to end he ended the hero that
he could never be at the beginning he
changed over the
like all of that makes sense but if in
like
2030 you know it's like hey you know
what
we we got we got a little iron man in us
we got it we got a tony stark we want to
show you we got a multiverse tony stark
who you know pepper snapped thanos away
and so he was left to survive and now he
raised his kid
you know whatever version that is but
you know nostalgia is a big part of
why the marvel the mcu works and you got
to want it
and it's got to be gone for a while
until you know
whatever the hell it is it's true you
could take like a decade
off come back and make a [ __ ] king's
ransom
and everyone would be like way happier
to see him then than they would
be to see him come back now and i'm
saying they would be happy to see him
come back now
but you know imagine that absence and if
you don't know what's coming
and you're just sitting there in some
like random ass marvel movie and
suddenly it's [ __ ] tony stark is back
for half the movie um that would be
amazing what if
i live in your fictional [ __ ] world
who was the other guest
the other guest was dave chappelle
interview the chappelle interview is
fantastic
like he he's so um
intelligence the wrong word articulate
is the wrong word but his perspective on
his own career
yeah you know his perspective on his
career you know his perspective on where
he lives and why he lives there like
they shoot it in his hometown of like
yellow springs ohio
and why he lives there because his
father was from there and so he grew up
there and
and how he feels about fame he's like
fame is awesome like celebrity i have no
patience for but fame
is kind of cool like i'm all about that
he's like but fame evaporates with
regularity
so i'm not famous in this town because
they see me every day
you know and so they know me and i can
you know the bosom of this community is
strong enough that it's
it's lovely to be here um so i'll make
you know
30 40 50 movies in my career but i'm
never moving to hollywood i'm never
moving to new york like why would i do
that i'm raising my kids here
um and talking about walking away from
chappelle show and talking about
you know his stand-up at the moment
and and his desires to kind of be out
there on the edge a little bit and say
things that make people feel
uncomfortable and
it's a it was it was a way more
rewarding watch than the downey junior
one was
and not because i'd like either of them
better or worse you know like i'm i'm
not that big a fan of
dave chappelle's current iteration of
stand-up comedy
but to listen to him talk about it and
to listen to dave talk about it and
these two guys who are sort of titans of
the craft
talking about their sort of conditions
of comedy is just it's fantastic
illuminating
worth watching all right okay for sure
it's and it's an easy hour
to go down two hours if you if you do
the double feature
um all right man there you got some tips
kids some [ __ ] to watch
meanwhile we got some news to do did you
please
listen we got some news you know the
lead story of the news is
the last thing we watched over the
weekend or potentially the first thing
mandalorian season two episode one the
marshall
dropped over the weekend oh my lord j.c
are you there with us
on the back did we lose him i am i am
here
do you see me now you did you watch uh
mandalorian as well
i did all right i like your princess
leia cosplay
no help us jc your
only hope um all right let's uh talk
about it the
um uh this is the first episode i
believe that was directed by favreau
mm-hmm yeah one you know he didn't do
any of season one he wrote this episode
and directed it
um i it was very baby yoda light
which is totally fine um because it was
so
tuscan raider heavy and i found that
story
uh so fascinating uh doing the
the crate dragon of course was cool and
whatnot but like
doing the sign language semi
tuscan raider sign language
like we just spent more time with those
characters than anybody ever had
before and they were like suddenly we
were like i want to watch a whole
[ __ ] episode about their culture
and [ __ ] like that it was
insanely well um written and then of
course it just had like the
adventure going for it and
[ __ ] boba fett like but
two boba fetts you know yeah the fets
one where you're like you know as you're
watching the episode you're like oh
so that's how they're doing boba fett
it's just his armor
and this is a random dude in the armor
fine and they told a great story
and all a fantastic like was basically
justified in space
um everything was copacetic and then at
the end
they showed the real [ __ ] boba fett
and you're like oh my god so is this
going to be the runner for the season is
he going to be chasing down his armor or
is he just in the next episode or what
like
it's it was a you know just as you were
like man what a satisfying episode they
were like
boba [ __ ] fat real fat um i loved it
i thought it was
compelling as [ __ ] and i was like i
can't read i'm going to binge the whole
thing and i forgot these [ __ ] only
dropped one episode a week
no more for you yeah what about you
i loved it and i'll actually i pull i'll
pull this out
this is a top star wars galaxy
trading card from like 1995
that shows a like the first artist
rendering of boba fett without his
helmet on
and he has the timothy oliphant white
messy quaffed hair so my first
impression of that was oh my god they
went back
to like old-school eu
star wars it wouldn't be surprising they
pulled a pearl
out of the crate dragon and that was
from like a [ __ ] card game wasn't it
uh they referenced it in the knights of
the old republic video game that's
it is where it is but it's in all sorts
of stories
uh it was there's so much cool stuff uh
i guess the
tuscan i think in the
season one who they hired to communicate
with the
mandalorian actually is uh
knows american sign language and so they
actually hired somebody to help make it
more
real and add diversity kind of behind
the scenes which is also really cool
yeah they said it's not a straight asl
translation
it's more tsl tuscan sign language but
very very close like they said in spirit
like this would be the
intergalactic version of it but such a
like great [ __ ] cool idea
um and like boy they really leaned into
the western this time around
like all last season it was like oh it's
like a western uh crossed with
you know um usagi jimbo or something
like that or
lone wolf and cub rather you saw jimbo
and um
this this first episode it was like this
just feels like
every western i hated watching on tv
when i was a kid
over the course of an hour and like
please put the cartoons back on but
since it's set in space
with boba fett armor and [ __ ] and tuscan
raiders i was like
this is the greatest [ __ ] story of
all time
but it did have a very like classic
you know we got to work together to save
the small town
before you move on you know it all of it
just [ __ ] worked man like it's one of
those things where
i never watched that show ever and go
like
uh man i wish i was doing that i'm just
happy to watch that show and go like ah
man i wish there was another episode to
watch right now
like i it's it's inventive while being
while homaging uh
something we thought we'd you know
tasted six ways to sunday
there's there's flavor left in that
[ __ ]
chewing gum you know what i'm saying
like for years people like ah [ __ ]
star wars
these cats like [ __ ] favor and felony
proven like number you could chew this
[ __ ] forever it's like an everlasting
gop stopper
and just when you think you've [ __ ]
gotten through all right i know what's
inside
there's another layer and it's tastier
than what was on the outside
they're killing it man absolutely
killing it what'd you think mark
i hated it no i didn't i didn't i just
had to do that awesome
what was your what's your writerly take
on it um
no i mean i i i
i dug it i dug it for sure i think that
the show looks as good as a show can
look
i think that you know if you're going to
give me a straight up western in space
then you know making timothy olyphant
your marshall
marshall cobb that's his name like
marshall cobb vance
like you know yeah all day every day
i'll take that
um it's it's it's very
plotty in a way that that i'm not even
gonna say surprises me
just you know like he he goes to this
boxing
match to meet up with a contact you can
tell him how to find mandalorian because
he needs mandalorians to find
where the kid is from even though he's
an expert tracker and should kind of
already know this but other mandos will
know it
and so then he goes to tatooine because
he heard about some armor and then he
finds the armor
but it's this guy and then they gotta
kill it like it's very just like
i'm gonna do this and then do this and
then it's a lot of and then
as opposed to and what it in terms of
writing like that makes me
feel um like oh [ __ ] i don't know how to
write it all
like that's how you feel
um it it just made me want more of an
emotional reason for him to be doing
this stuff
um you know one that's a little less you
know abstract the abstraction of
i gotta find this contact who can tell
me where the mandalorians are
um and then by the end of the episode
that doesn't really pay off
it's just like oh no i met a cool dude
and i let him keep some armor and then
there's a boba fett back there
but the original want that he was trying
to satisfy
over the course of this episode there's
no progress towards meeting that wand
um and what he wants is i want to bring
this kid home
right and he gets no information over
the course of it that leads
not even like at the end where it's like
well [ __ ] i've heard of a
you know unless it's you know boba fett
will eventually be that thing but
your hero hasn't accomplished that the
the rest of the world has sort of
figured that out
um i say all of this having thoroughly
and totally enjoyed it
you know like it's fun like it's super
cool like it's dune
meets you know high noon and you know
it's
classic western traffic it had a very
high noon flavor to it now that you
mentioned it i'm like yeah there was a
very high noon to it
you know and and i appreciate them you
know the first season you know i was
talking to jc a little bit about this
before like it's got your magnificent
seven episode right where it's
okay uh we gotta train up this village
so they can do
battle against the bandits who keep
stealing their food but it's you know
they're in a scout walker and it's laser
bandits and you're not in a farm you're
in like a weird rice paddy alien moon
farm
this is just a [ __ ] western this is
just like mysterious stranger rolls into
town
with a quest finds a you know a weird
odd person to team up with to go and you
know
kill the big baddie who lives in a cave
cool
i'll tell you for it i'll take nine more
episodes like that
adventure you mentioned to mark before
we went live also
when they go to kill the crate dragon
they move from a 2 3 5 cinema scope
aspect ratio
into 16 by 9 and then they move back to
two three
five as the mando rides off into the
sunset what was the philosophy behind
that you think
i i guess um somebody had told me that
they used to do that
in the old like sergio leone spaghetti
westerns
they'd alter this the uh aspect ratio
based on the scene
so i think it was literally a call back
to old kind of like serialized
uh westerns back in the day
which is kind of a cool little thing
very man
can you imagine having that much power
and that much freedom like you created a
show
the whole [ __ ] world loves so you're
like i'm gonna do some [ __ ]
that sergio leone might have done just
to see if it [ __ ] like see if anybody
noticed me
they uh the other thing you guys were
talking about mark mentioned timothy
oliphant and of course if you're gonna
hire a
sheriff you hire timothy oliphant to
play but what they don't
people aren't catching is that the actor
who played the weekway bartender
was also played a bartender in deadwood
so when he walks in he's like we quay
uh he's actually acting with somebody
he's
played that exact same scene out with in
deadwood
that's wild man was weak way supposed to
be somebody
we that's an interesting thing because
he looked like a skiff guard and
from return of the jedi and his name was
somewhat similar
well we quay is a species so there were
weak ways that were skiff guards in the
han jabba's palace so it is a little bit
off-putting that
he goes in and basically refer it'd be
like me being like
a jersey boy or hey human or hey
yeah irishman or whatever uh it's a
little weird but
you know i guess they have that kind of
report and then again everybody calls
the mandalorian
mando yeah which is super weird because
like mandalorian is also a faith
and also an ethnology like it's it would
be like
and i'm only saying this joke because a
jewish person told it to me
careful hey jew how are you
[Laughter]
slow down slow down um it is
uh it's it uh continues to dazzle and
delight though
um yeah i mean i'm bored for sure can't
wait to see where it goes next
i'll let before i get back but but was
i was a little disappointed that it was
i forgot that they're like you know one
at a time
like they do that boys method where they
yeah and you know
why i didn't know that is because last
time
i it was over when i watched mandalorian
so i went bang bang bang bang bang
so this time i was like oh one was great
i can't wait to watch two and i was like
where the [ __ ] did it go
um before i bounce off the street this
stream i'll
throw out when this stream's over i did
two hours of deep dive on mandalorian on
the scum and villainy twitch
with calling out all the easter eggs and
all the deep dives like the little
boba fett one i mentioned on here so
very nice all right we're gonna find
that
uh twitch.tv slash scum and villainy
cantina
so when we're done here after q a go pop
over there and you can watch two hours
of me
babbling about mandolin excellent
um all right amanda what else we got
now we got freaking moon night this this
broke like
two days three days after our last
podcast but it's still
too good not to be the top story oscar
isaac
it broke in a couple different ways too
because before the oscar isaacs of it
broke which is fantastic
that's great casting he's an amazing
actor
and the fact that they're like oscar
isaac is your oscar ozzie's is gonna be
your
your moon night like that shows you how
[ __ ] much money they're willing to
spend
how serious they are about it um how
wha what direction it's gonna take
because he could be charming as [ __ ] but
like we know the moon knight character
mark spector is like [ __ ] crazy
so like there'll be places for him to go
um with the character which is kind of
uh kind of awesome
but it broke after initially
like there was word that they heard like
nick crowell was being considered for
moon knight did you see that like that
diggs
and nick kroll were being considered
from moonlight and that's the story that
broke on
twitter first and then like within
half an hour of that story breaking
suddenly they were like oscar isaacs
is your moon night right but that
definitely feels like it's one of those
you know scooping website so we're like
no rumor has it
they're looking to cast multiple mark
specters to reflect the odd the other
parts of his personality
um which is that what it is i
it could be true it could be just we
heard these names and so we went with it
and then the truth is
it's oscar isaac no idea if the reality
is
here's the various aspects of his
personality
um that sort of ebb and flow like the
phases of the moon
yeah that would be kind of dope that's a
cool idea man allows you to cast other
people and [ __ ]
yeah because you know he's got what and
these two other personalities there's a
cabbie
named jake lockley and a millionaire
playboy named steven grant
yes mark spector
sure yeah that you know that's [ __ ]
pretty dope idea actually
yeah completely different people playing
those personalities
rather than one guy just being like ah
i'm sure he could pull it off he's a
great actor but it'd be kind of much
cooler to see like
i don't know other people representing
his others
yeah um so yeah i mean there's still no
date on when this thing is happening
because
you know everything is far enough out i
mean they have
they've got a showrunner jeremy slater
who uh who developed and wrote on
netflix's
umbrella academy um who's leading the
writing team
um but you know no production start date
has been set
you know and marvel had no comment so
it's happening
eventually um good news very good news
look forward
saw a piece somewhere online this week i
forget
where it was what website but somebody
confirmed that wanda was
indeed the villain in in uh
the uh multiverse of madness
yeah which made me go like oh [ __ ] and
then as much as i want to watch one
division now i want it even more
um i hope that's the case i hope she is
the big bad
in multiverse that would be badass
they've done a good job building that
character's arc and stuff
at the end of end game she was so
[ __ ] haunted and whatnot so you can
kind of tell
something something bad's coming man
some bad's coming
um elsewhere in the mcu um
this month november um the daredevil
rights
revert back to marvel netflix
so you know there there are no plans you
know that had been announced and made
public to the world
as to where daredevil will appear who
will be playing daredevil
the internet clearly wants charlie cox
to come back because
he was so great as matt murdock but at
the time
yeah yeah for sure and so who the hell
knows but at the very least
um that character is back in the fold as
is
i have to assume everybody who came with
that character
um so you know you'll get your you'll
get your karen you'll get your kingpin
you know where the punisher comes along
or not i'm not sure
um but [ __ ] yeah daredevil
uh they can play with that character now
anytime they want
over him yes cinematic universe fingers
and
you know they got a spider-man movie
coming and it's true
i was gonna say like oh my god wouldn't
it be amazing to see daredevil in a
movie we've seen that
it's happened it's happened before we
know
we know the guy who played him to have
charlie cox swinging through manhattan
with tom holland
would be kind of fun even just a minor
appearance like at one point like you
know they were talking about
he might what if peter needs a lawyer
it's like yeah man that'd be fun
but then people were like if peter needs
a lawyer it's gonna be
she-hulk and i was like yeah i guess
that makes more sense
because they're getting ready to make a
she-hulk tv show or
are they you still don't know
lonnie was like i don't know what you're
talking about yeah she-hulk i don't know
she-hulk yeah really um
elsewhere leaving the mcu for a stretch
um hbo is making a hell razor tv series
and did you know this i you know i could
see that
was an anthology um it's unclear
exactly what form it's going to take um
but i mean what what is clear is that
david gordon-green
um is going to direct at least at the
very least the initial episodes
mark for haydn from battlestar galactica
and swamp thing
and michael doherty from trick or treat
are running the show and now clive
barker has joined
as an executive producer um
you allow the guy that created the
[ __ ] ship he involved
generous of them very very cool um
the uh uh mark what did you say mark
bernheim
for haydn yeah ryan i always think of
him as the guy
from darkhorse like he was a comic book
guy absolutely yeah about the aliens
uh first for i think the first aliens
comic books he did if i remember
correctly and stuff
but wow he's a big tv dude now right
he's a very big tv dude yeah he's
it he's a full-on shirt and it has been
for a while i think he might have cut
his teeth on the
flash back in the day really
maybe he might go that far back i think
i like i
i think it
maybe there's a pr the tv show i guess
maybe like for some reason
i've got him as like maybe he wrote the
actual comic book for dc back in the day
um but yeah that it's crazy man that
dude like i remember
reading his name in comic books as a
comic book writer now he's a [ __ ] big
time showrunner that's awesome
yeah well i can i can track and let's
see time cop
the tv series that was it back in 97.
um time cop like a dark horse book
um i think i mean it was a movie first
and then a
then a dark horse book perhaps
um the mask
you wrote the story for that um
smallville
falling skies capricorn battle star
heroes
yeah yeah he's been working for a while
he's been working for a while
um that's hemlock grove constantine he
was a showrunner on
on the nbc series he was an ep on
daredevil
fancy meeting that guy um
on daredevil netflix version yep
yeah yeah yeah he's been he's been in
the nerd space for a good long while
[ __ ] rock star oh yeah um
and so for him to to get to strap in
with you know
[ __ ] clive barker sounds pretty cool
um yeah you could tell i could see that
being a [ __ ] series
will tear your soul
[Laughter]
that still works that's what i was
talking about i'm not even the best
version of that guy i just get it off
the [ __ ]
top of my head could you imagine if
you've had some real practice
and you've got that that uh
tenor in your voice where you're just
like you'll tear your
soul apart
and you gotta put all the pins in your
head though man well i mean
nobody's doing that these days i'll
probably cg that [ __ ] in his face right
probably who do you think we'll do in
practical and somebody's gonna sit there
and do the makeup job
yeah yeah what are you doing back there
man look at that man
i'm not doing nothing over here um all
right what else we got
um did you i mean i know that your video
game playing has been sporadic over the
last
15 years or so to say the least to say
the least
but there is a game series called
assassins creed
oh yeah i'm very familiar with that they
made a very unsuccessful
film about it right they did they did um
and so that
fast bender fassy fessy um
an unsuccessful movie doesn't dissuade
anybody from spending
millions more into doing now a
live-action tv series
um so far nobody's doing it
except for netflix netflix is the they
made a deal with ubisoft who published
the game
so it's gonna be a netflix show it's
gonna be netflix jam and it feels
you know netflix at this point in its
evolution is less focused on the
american market and way more invested in
the international market
because that's where growth for them
they see growth being like they may or
may not have
as many people as they're going to get
in the us
but there's a whole [ __ ] ton more people
out there in the rest of the world and
so they're slowly opening in other
countries and other markets and so doing
a show like
assassin's creed which the video games
have been
in sort of fantastical places as like
the
renaissance italy and constantinople
and egypt and paris and it gives you an
international flavor to begin with
absolutely you know and a lot of it is
period um which is also very attractive
i think to them
especially on the heels of something
like the witcher which is one of their
most watched series ever and feels like
you're in
you know medieval england even though
it's you know whatever made up place
no it's got that game of thronesy thing
to it too
totally might as well be westeros um
so yeah they're super excited about it
and you know it it
makes you know to that end a ton of
sense
a ton of sense so yeah they're looking
for a writer to help
shape the take on it and then i'm sure
they will spend every last dime
in making you never played the game
never saw the movie
we'll definitely give the tv show up a
roll
a cursory watch just to see at the very
least what is the idea behind the
what is it is a guy that he's an
assassin
he's one of them assassins with a creed
yeah yeah it's
uh you know apollo creed assassin
we're in the lead man you should have
began with that um
it is a little bit convoluted in that uh
it takes place
in two dual time zones one is like sort
of the
near future from the trailer for the
movie it's like two different
time zones yeah it's like a near future
kind of um
you know big conspiracy thing where
there's some evil corporation that's
trying to
to uh to create or unlock some kind of
apple of the universe that will give
them the power of creation but in order
to do it
they need to track through the genetic
memory of an
ancestor who at one point had been an
assassin in this
creed this club of dudes who knows where
this thing is buried so it's a very sort
of long route
towards like treasure hunting in in the
modern day
and so they find somebody who's a
distant distant descendant of
this very specific assassin and they put
him in this machine
and that machine allows the user to live
in that dude's shoes
and walk in that dude's shoes distant
past and so it's the sort of like
back and forth between these two time
zones the future stuff
is way less interesting than the actual
oh here i am
in you know ancient greece doing ancient
greek [ __ ] or here i am
on a pirate ship in the high seas doing
cool pirate [ __ ] here i am at the you
know american revolution
um doing awesome cool revolutionary [ __ ]
and not here i am strapped in this
machine
um i'll be honest with you i tuned out
because i just realized
we've got we can literally access
twitter now
while we're doing this we could yes we
could always do it at the bar too but
it'd be rude to scroll through a [ __ ]
phone and [ __ ] but
mark wiggins on twitter said uh back
when we're having the conversation about
robert downey jr
what if they brought him back for demon
in a bottle
which on one hand i'm like oh that'd be
dope but on the other hand it'd be so
weird because it's like
he saved the universe now he can't save
himself from a drink
you know angry drunk yeah it just i
it feels like they missed their window
to kind of do that he's he's lived way
too big a life at this point and [ __ ]
like yeah i'd be inclined to be like
look [ __ ] save the universe let
him drink
is they flirted with a little bit in
iron man 2 when he's got to drink that
sludge that allows his
you know his heart to to keep on
pumping or whatever and so he's reliant
on this
stuff in a bottle that's actually doing
him more damage than it is good and
his ongoing dependence on this juice
that he's got to drink like
i guess they kind of did it without
doing that yeah without like
we're doing drunk iron man because we
have to sell toys to kids
is probably the consideration of like
yeah we're not going to do that
[ __ ] point man yeah they're like look
how about we do it metaphorically [ __ ]
um no [ __ ] remains says i love when you
both get serious and talk about the real
[ __ ] but i also love when you go
the other way and make me forget all the
real [ __ ] for a moment
oh that's kind yes you're welcome
uh and if anybody's got questions man
throw them up in that [ __ ] thread
because i could pull them right now
[ __ ] jc i don't need his help no more i
can pull questions myself
i'm my own man yes meanwhile i say who
i say when i say who um all right so
what else we got um the ray
fisher saga continues again what's going
on there
well the only thing i know about the ray
fisher saga this week is that he went as
cyborg for halloween which i thought was
[ __ ] adorable oh did he
even wear a cyborg costume he posted
that's cute
that's cute um i was maybe jealous i was
like why didn't i wear the store-bought
silent bob costume take a [ __ ]
picture
it is that is far cuter than uh his new
wave of accusations that he's leveling
on uh on warner brothers oh what are
they um
basically he's amplifying his prior
comments by indicating that racial
issues played a part in the decisions
that led to his
claimed mistreatment the erasure of
people of color from the 2017
theatrical version of justice league was
neither an accident nor coincidence
fisher contended in a recent forbes
interview
citing several changes including the
diminishment of his screen time
the allegations add a new angle to prior
complaints about toxic conduct
conduct conduct by whedon and other
executives
for one thing says fisher the cast and
crew were told that zach had hand-picked
josh to finish the film for him
i didn't find out until after the
reshoots that that was a complete lie
i heard whispers and rumblings of things
being off behind the scenes but nothing
concrete
concrete until much later
what's going on with you tonight man
you're like all the basic two-syllable
words
are really gonna [ __ ] me up
reading i do this so little today i
forgot english
works it's uh it's a vestige of me
watching shit's creek
and mispronouncing everything like moira
they had us go out to san diego comic
con in 2017 and say
zach picked joss and that joshua's a
great guy i still haven't
remember that i remember that clip he's
since uh rescinded everything he said
very much so i still have the email with
those talking points
basically the studio said you have to
say these things you kept the receipts
kept the receipts um fisher amplified
his comments claiming the abusive and
unprofessional atmosphere on the set was
cultivated behind closed doors even
before snyder departed the project
prior to justice league's reshoot
process um says fisher
uh blatantly racist conversations were
had and entertained on multiple
occasions
by former and current top-level execs at
warner brothers pictures
decision makers that participate in
those racist conversations were jeff
johns
john berg and current warner brothers
pictures group chairman toby emmerich
okay i realized we know two of those
dudes aren't gonna have their names on
uh
the zack snyder justice league very much
so yeah those guys are being
sort of stripped of their previously
contractual titles
um yeah how do you get away with that i
don't know
like i remember hearing somewhere that
like the warner brothers had tried
to get andrew kreisberg's name off of
like you know the flash and supergirl or
the flash
but uh but couldn't do it because you
know according to the writer's guild
like hey man you did the work
if we fired you your name still gets to
be on all those
um yeah man i wonder i wonder what
happens in this instance
yeah maybe the producer's guild doesn't
quite have that same
um ironclad requirements for producer
names i'm not sure
oh toby emmer toby emerick um
fisher continues i realized that the
notes i ended up getting from john's
during reshoots were just a coded
version of the racist things he was
saying with
saying with behind closed doors with the
other execs there's an extra with him
there
a lot of what these guys were doing was
in an effort to prevent themselves from
being fired during att's merger with
time warner
i plan on getting much more specific
about each of these guys after the
investigation is over
this interview is just the abridged
version
[Music]
in the words of uh his cartoon
counterpart booyah
what uh um where do you see this all
going martin
uh it is it is un like i on the one hand
i respect what he's doing because he's
like listen
all of this [ __ ] happened i don't think
it was kosher in any way shape or form
and it will continue to happen to other
people who are not me if somebody
doesn't say
this is how it went down on justice
league here's my experience hopefully
everybody can benefit from it
that's a very altruistic way to look at
it because it seems as if on the other
side of this you know i
i i don't know what his end game is if
it's
anything beyond just telling the truth
which is a valid and totally
you know reasonable and respectable end
game but if it is
you know to try and and reignite a
career that he felt was
damaged by his experience on justice
league
i don't i don't know if this kind of
um sort of revelation roulette
roulette there it is um is in his best
three words you've mispronounced in this
yeah
although one of them was french
um yeah man that's uh i mean
well he's taken care of by zach that's
for sure like we're gonna see a lot more
of rey's work
in justice league than we had previously
seen
but uh yeah it doesn't sound like
i mean i i can't imagine warner bros is
gonna be like hey let's make more movies
together
right yeah i think you know the once
upon a time
on a release calendar cyborg film is
probably
was never happening but it is definitely
not happening at least not with
we uh still show up in flash you think
um you know i don't know i don't know i
mean maybe
maybe some of some of what he's going
through and some of his
sort of adventures with warner brothers
hr one of the up shots could be
all right hey man you know what if we a
take these guys names off of it penalize
them in an appropriate way
and then get you in a flash movie you
know does that
help to get us somewhere close to an
equitable resolution
i don't know i honestly don't know um
but but yeah and it doesn't quite feel
as if
i mean jason momoa came out in support
of him and says you know i stand with
you brother you know
oh yeah my man um but
he doesn't seem to have rallied around
him the same kind of
support that say john boyega got when he
decided to kind of rail against some of
the
the racist actions of a the world and be
his experiences making a star wars movie
um
so i don't know i don't know it's it's
way too early to tell
what the actual fallout from this will
be except that he
he's down to keep talking about it and
he's down to keep leveling these
accusations so
that's why it's like all right ray
fisher watched episode
six what's what's he got to say now
um this is completely apropos of nothing
but
we uh i'm sorry i'll be honest i'm at
chicago time so i'm still like [ __ ]
i'm sleeping goggle time plus
daylight savings time oh you're missing
that as well plus a couple joints
um uh canna miss on
twitter jamie pattiers
uh says uh she misses us and the cantina
so much
uh she asked do you think there's a
possibility that uh
og blockbuster is going to streaming she
said she rented the hunt
three times then bought it saw the
invisible man
her last theatrical movie at citywalk
with which he blurred then rented and
bought
so i guess her question is do you ever
think
there is the possibility og
blockbuster's going straight to
streaming
so bypassing theatrical altogether
you know i think that that it's always a
value judgment on the part of the
studios whether or not they think
there will ever get to be a theatrical
experience as robust as it had been
before the pandemic
um if they can carry this level of debt
on their sort of fiscal year rolls and
say yeah no
we made no money last year because the
movie we spent 600 million dollars
making
could not come out um you know there was
there was another
story this week that uh that tickled me
in in the weirdest sort of way
is that apparently um mgm and
i think it's sony were trying to find
somebody to buy
no time to die off of them the latest
james bond movie so that it would
go it would skip theatrical altogether
and go streaming right they were asking
for 600 million dollars
um was the price tag and you know nobody
bought because that's an insane amount
of money
to have to lay out for a bond picture
um even though it's entirely possible
they might have made it back who who the
hell knows
you know if apple buys it do they
figure out a way to sell it to you the
way they sell every other kind of movie
to you totally you know would you would
people pay
50 bucks to watch a bond movie at home
they might maybe
but that's a that's a huge financial hit
for somebody to take on an experiment
um we saw this happen once with tenant
like
they're now they're just openly talking
about how it was a failed experiment for
them and whatnot they've been
you know probably lost a bunch of money
not because like chris nolan's not a
great filmmaker but because the whole
world's not ready to go out to see any
movie right now
yeah you know and then mulan on the
other hand was like you know we're
skipping theatrical entirely
and we're gonna come home and you know
they did okay
you know i think they made something
like you know they they spent 200
million dollars on the budget they made
like 240 250 million dollars back in the
disney premier
you know um release on disney plus
is that a good return on investment for
them well no they expected to make a
billion dollars in the international box
office and
couldn't couldn't make that happen so
we're in this weird nether space between
you know these movies were all made in a
pre-existing condition
and you know it's impossible to to
actually
recoup this the the expenditures of that
pre-existing condition
in this current environment it's like
we're in a completely different economy
and the old rules don't apply and so
who knows like somebody in the uk
started like a kickstarter or a gofundme
like can we all if we all chipped in
britain's
buy no time to die off of mgm and then
release it ourselves on the internet
all we need you guys is 600 million
dollars to do it
could you imagine i mean i number one i
could see the internet pulling that off
but at the same time it's just like you
made 600 million and you bought a james
bond baby
[Laughter]
you didn't actually cure the disease
that has
something very important uh jamie also
points out
um as she always does that legion
has one of the best versions of charles
xavier
and promised that you'll love it you
still haven't watched legion yet have
you
watched the first season you have in the
first season they added charles xavier
in the last season apparently
yeah aubry plaza dan stevens
jermaine clement and gene gene smarts in
it
are amazing i love her man she's amazing
yeah i got to get to it i got my i got
my discs that jamie gave me
so i will get to it eventually yeah i
just i i
appreciated the first season but it was
uh it was a little too
slow going for me um and a little too
i mean cerebral is the wrong word given
who it's about and what's going on
but it was uh at times very pleased with
itself for existing
um more than was interested in
entertaining me
um that might have changed over the
course of the season i don't know but
the first season was like oh i see what
you're doing
captain did uh fargo does fargo all the
time yeah noah holly
um all right what other news do we have
well you know the last
big bit of news is the the saddest news
of the
of the weekend is uh on uh
i want to say was yesterday sunday um
that news came down the pike that sir
sean connery
passed away at the age of 90 years old
break out the bagpipes man
that's right 90 years old sean connery
passes away
um you know i my my experience with sean
connery he wasn't my first bond
you know like yeah mine either he was uh
my roger moore was my bond
yeah you know so i grew up with roger
moore and you know there's there's
things to be said in roger moore's
credit for sure but he was like the
the kind of daffy happy-go-lucky bond um
you know the sort of reflexive pivot
away from the kind of serious
you know stern you know kind of like
good time boy but like he was he was
always this
the duality of sean connery's bond was
that he looked like a gentleman but
behaved like a bruiser
to be uh to be to put it in the parlance
of our uh contemporaries this being
uh fat man beyond the um
let's say that the sean connery bond was
tim burton
and the roger moore bond was very much
joel schumacher yes i mean that
the connery bond could either also be
like the nolan
you know yeah that too that too i mean
daniel craig sort of got there also but
daniel craig was just trying to be sean
connery
um but uh and you know to diminish him
by only claiming that no he's james bond
he's best known for james bond
as they would do when he won the oscar
for the unfor uh you know for the uh
untouchables
play the james bond theme as he walks
out to pick up his trophy
um for a movie that has nothing to do
with james bond
he did a lot of other stuff in his
career like there were seven james bond
movies and the dude worked
kind of incessantly um from like 1962
tonight to 2004. he had this one period
in the 90s where he exploded again
i think it was right after hunt for red
october was so huge and he was like
white hot again so he wasn't like the
rock
and medicine man and like just
on and on he was getting uh like flick
after flick i mean the dude worked
consistently he was never
didn't really have a down time in his
period his career
felt like but uh like even when he
wasn't
you know remember when he started like
losing his hair and everybody was like
what the [ __ ]
not james bond uh he was in time bandits
you know
about that period and stuff like
a cinema legend and whatnot but in the
90s
he like had this weird career resurgence
almost like a
like uh like travolta to some degree
where suddenly
he was the go-to guy for everything and
he kept being cast
over and over again might have had
something to do with him being of a
certain age at that point
yeah i think it was also like the
goodwill garnered by
indiana jones in the last crusade yeah
of like
you know which i i want to say was like
89
um or maybe 91. it was definitely in
that zone
but it was you know here he is playing
indiana jones dad
and like this kind of weird daughtering
charismatic
you know latter-day adventurer
um and the world fell in love with him
again
and that i think helped to kick off that
sort of like i'm going to be in the name
of the rose i'm going to be in first
night i'm going to be in hunter in
october and i'm going to be in the
presidio and i'm going to like the rock
and this
sort of ongoing swirl of i'm just going
to be the cool old dude
who kind of holds down the center of
this thing or do killer cameos remember
robin hood kevin costner's robin hood he
shows up as
king richard king richard um one of my
favorite roles of his was
robin and miriam when he played the old
robin hood
um with audrey hepburn playing
maid marion really like wonderful
adventure
story um you know with and and very
butch and sundance
um and it was it followed if i remember
correctly butch cassidy and the sundance
kid
um of of like you know old characters
who have gotten old
um and boy he wore that one incredibly
well i love that role
what's your favorite sean connery i mean
i think
i i think it's probably a toss-up
between hunford october
and highlander which is another like i'm
i just took this movie i'm gonna do two
weeks in spain and then i'm gonna go
back to my house
and do what i do um and i and i
kind of loved that and i just love this
weird
ebullience he brought to everything
there was always this sense of
i'm having the best time i'm i love
doing this i'm also really good at this
um there was this amazing twitter thread
um over the weekend um from a
screenwriter named brian koppelman
yeah who was talking about a movie that
he was um you know hired to write
or rewrite um that sean connor said
we're doing a sean connery rewrite
we might get him for the lead so um you
got to meet with him
in new york he's like well we can't go
to ls no he's in new york that's fine
um he's going to come to your office at
nine o'clock in the morning and give you
some notes
and it's like like lo and behold nine
o'clock in the morning sean connery
knocks on the door like not a
not a hair late not here early like on
time
and uh you know walks in it's like my
name is sean it's not certain it's not
mr connery if that's the case i'm
walking out of here
and then proceeds over a couple of days
to like give notes on it is that the
notes every note was great
every note was made the script better
you know like
decades of having made movies the dude
has forgotten more about how it goes
than most people know
and every note was fantastic and so
you know they went off and they they did
the rewrite and the studio was like
great we're gonna hire new writers i was
like no
we it's only us like it's just sean
wants us to do this i go
okay i guess you're doing it and then
like they had to call him in the bahamas
when he went on vacation
and then or no i think he lived in the
bahamas for a stretch yeah yeah he was
living in the bahamas for a long time
in the bahamas and then um you know the
the director they were getting a
conference call with the director who
goes unnamed in the twitter thread but
um it uh if you paid attention to the
details it was easy enough to define who
it was
um who was it um it is
um [ __ ] how did i just forget
um brett ratner
is that right yes it's brett ratner what
was the project you know
um the project um seems to be
um this thing that was called josiah
stone
um or josiah's canon about some like
holocaust survivor who
like goes on a tear of revenge or
something like that
um never got made i think once john
connery disappeared
but um you know they they get on the on
the call with his director and the
director is like we're gonna have this
underwater action scene and sean's like
i want you to tell me how you're gonna
do this
and it's like it's gonna be movie magic
baby he's like no
i want you to tell me every shot i've
been making movies since your father
before your father learned how to tug
one out so you're gonna tell me how
we're doing this
and he had no answer for him and then
one day sean
sees this director in the player's box
of the french open
which is how you get to like brett
ratner was dating um
serena williams which is why he was
always at these tennis matches he's like
he's a bucket of smoke like i'm not
making this movie he doesn't know what
he's doing he's not his heart isn't in
it so
i'm out and like sean yeah compliments
said like he's he
sean connery said one of my favorite put
downs i've ever heard my entire life
oh he's a bucket of smoke
[Laughter]
that's a [ __ ] class he put down yeah
i met him not met him like you know
shook his [ __ ] hand
but we were over we went to the
edinburgh film festival a few years back
and you know it was in scotland and he's
the king of scotland practically so um
you know they the opening night party
for the film festival is at the
edinburgh
museum the art museum in the castle it's
[ __ ] gorgeous like literally a castle
and there's all this old art and stuff
so you know i'm there and i'm wearing my
long coat and i got
my jean shorts on jorts or whatever
um and there's you know
sean connery like we get in we're
walking around play place packed
everyone's got like drinks and
cocktail weenies and [ __ ] and all of a
sudden i see
sean connery standing there in full
scottish regalia with the kilt you know
and the
the rabbit fur that they wear in the
front and stuff like that looks like a
fanny pack but it goes on the front
so like full [ __ ]
dressed like the part um
and this is the weirdest thing he like
locked eyes on me and my outfit
like he was looking at my outfit like
how dare you
[ __ ] dress like that here um
with never said anything we didn't
exchange words and stuff but he gave me
the once
over like the bucket of smoke and
i remember like as i fully felt like
judged but i remember being like you're
judging my outfit right now like what
um that was my only interaction with sir
shaw this was the ceremonial gear of a
highlander
i know it looked like did you feel the
quickening
but boy he just looked the part of a
legend in the room man
he made that outfit work um which he did
in uh
remember he was in the original avengers
avengers the one we don't talk that much
about what he talks about we
[ __ ] had a weather machine this is
only the beginning
my name is auguste de winter
[Laughter]
um what else do we have on sir sean
connery is there a
an upside we've done the upside is there
a downside well you know
it's it is the peculiarity of a person
having been famous
for so long um especially from a time
in which the internet didn't exist and
you know while gossip columnists and
reporters were absolutely out
there you know one could say things in
the past
um about sort of beliefs that one holds
that wouldn't quite have the same impact
as they would today
namely sean connery seems to have had
uh nope he had a hot
take on star wars no he had a hot take
on spousal abuse um
his uh he he mentioned it and it's weird
because he's been he was like with his
wife
mish wasn't a michelin or something like
yeah i think so for long time decades
like four decades um but he said in a in
playboy magazine in 1965
i don't think there's anything
particularly wrong about hitting a woman
although i don't recommend doing it in
the same way you'd hit a man
an open-handed slap is justified if all
other alternatives fail
now this was 1965 the world was a
different place it's an awful thing
to say no matter what time you say it in
and you think that maybe time would have
softened
that particular perspective but 20 years
later he told me about checked in with
him again and he's like
barbara walters was like hey have you
changed your opinion he says
no uh i don't think it's good to slap a
woman he said at the time i don't think
it's that bad
i think it depends entirely on the
circumstances and if it merits it
if you've tried everything else and
women are pretty good at this they can't
leave it alone he explained
they want to have the last word and you
give them the last word but they're not
happy with the last word they want to
say it again
and get into a really provocative
situation then i think it's absolutely
right
i mean i with all due respect
that sounds like every conversation i've
ever had with
every person not just a woman so does
that
that would mean that by the end of all
these conversations i should have been
like
gentle maybe not so gentle open-handed
slap
um i can nobody needs just in case this
needs to be said i mean it is a
topsy-turvy world but
perhaps every once in a while it's good
to remind people
don't hit anybody don't hit anybody
anybody
like is even if you don't agree with
them i mean maybe if they're coming at
you with a gun
and [ __ ] or whatever [ __ ] defend
yourself sure but like
you you're never allowed to be so
frustrated with a person
that you hit them because you don't know
how to use your words
or yeah i mean great that's
crazy i i stand by that like 90 percent
i think you can punch a nazi in the face
if they're being like actively nazi
sure um but by and large if you
literally just have a disagreement with
a person yeah don't resort to violence
unless see the previous nazi clause um
in 2006 finally he seems to have either
learned
his lesson or learned not to speak about
it out loud
um it's unclear which is the truth but
he did say
to the times of london my view is i
don't believe that any level of abuse
against
women is ever justified under any
circumstances
full stop look at that he grew up he
grew up
or again was counseled sean please stop
saying this
it's been 40 years you shut up stop
[ __ ] saying that
so you know it's it it does go to show
that
that uh that no person is one thing
um and that every person is complicated
in their own complicated way
um he might well have been one of the
greatest movie stars to ever exist he
might well have been one of the best
actors to ever walk the planet
um but there was also absolutely this
part of his life that is reprehensible
um and and indefensible
and to to celebrate his work on one hand
but also to realize that he was
a a sort of less than perfect
by a great shot human being um i think
is fair
and yeah nobody's nobody's so great at
their job they're allowed to slap around
their wife
no no i mean and it's it's not yeah we
can celebrate
without if you're a boxer your job is to
slap people around
in a ring but we're not talking about
boxers we're talking about
briefs we're talking about babies
um yeah what a what a uh
bummer uh cloud to to uh the whole
affair
it is but i think it's it's it is worth
you know trying to put everything in
context
and you know it's possible to to both
celebrate
and with clear eyes look at a person's
life
and uh and take him for a man in full
and
i don't think we will ever see that kind
of actor again
i don't think we make actors this way
anymore you know that can
that seem to be able to do everything
you know who can you know be a tough guy
who can be a romantic lead who can do a
hitchcock movie who can be in
zardas and still also keep on working
after a movie like
zardoz this guy was in darby o'gill and
the little people
absolutely thank the leprechauns for
heaven's sakes and then became james
bond
yeah that's true he was singing
electrons
before that ever happened yeah
um so yes sean connery at 90 years old
um has uh has left this mortal coil
um the uh spectre
finally got him i guess indeed or
smersch
smersh that's right um
that's all the news we got that's the
end of the news brother there it is kids
that's all the news give it up for marky
collective news for you
all right casey pop your head in here
you got any questions
uh i do have some questions from the
chat
uh let's see uh braden gossey
said uh wants to know you have been
chosen to play
a new bond villain the character is
being developed around you
what is your gimmick and plan for world
domination
cat on my lap
i know this is i know this is out
outside the box
and you know try to come with me on this
but
i'm a bad guy and i pet a cat that's in
my lap all the time
no if it's a dog oh [ __ ] could you
imagine
they never show a bad guy with a dog you
know why um loves a dog
nobody likes cats never knows the cats
are behind all the bad [ __ ] in the world
um what would what would my gimmick be
meaning like you know what was that one
[ __ ] who was like
oh mr bond remember he took his [ __ ]
jaw out and [ __ ] oh yeah javier bardem
yes that was [ __ ] dope i remember
watching the movie and being like
i'm [ __ ] in man james bond suddenly
got very comic booking and [ __ ] that was
really
well he's like click click click
because he had the acid he bit the
[ __ ] acid pill
and it rotted out his jaw but it didn't
kill him
that's so [ __ ] up yeah i mean and
that's such a great one how do you top
that
other than like you know i had i had the
[ __ ] poison pill hidden in my crotch
and i [ __ ] sat on it wrong and it
burned my dick off and now i'm mad at
[ __ ] james bond
and i [ __ ] have the same scene where
i [ __ ] like hold on
and i crack my dick off and i'm like
look
what you did shake it not stirred
[Laughter]
um mark's uh a better writer than i am
you have an idea
oh i i'm still just too enthused with
you know
chromecock the unbatty
um i think my plan for world domination
is uh artificial intelligence um
i think that's that that's one way to to
absolutely frighten
a populace um i think my thing is
i was a um an adventurer
and a venturer um and i climbed a thing
and now like half of my body's bionic
um and i've sort of i'm i'm i'm reeling
from the loss of humanity basically i'm
cyborg
but less angry at warner brothers
um and uh
and so that way there's an awesome final
battle with bond because i'm half
[ __ ] ed 209 and half a person and
uh and yeah and i've caused the world's
machines to rise up against it
i like it um all right here's mine
okay i hate james bond
so much that i become
a woman hmm villain
to seduce him because we all know his
thing is that
and then i reveal that i'm the guy from
his past to
you know [ __ ] my dick got burned off
or whatever the [ __ ] and
and then i i go at him tooth and nail
that is totally a movie that uh i mean
tell me
like if you were in the third act of a
james bond movie and like suddenly the
female lead was like i was once
roger and i hated your [ __ ] guts bond
you'd be like
wait a second this is the plot of
[ __ ] ace ventura
this the crying game i thought wasn't
that the plot of base ventura wasn't it
like sean
young i think so yeah like i don't
remember that very well
i don't remember the weird like
transphobia in ace ventura but i believe
that it was there
i think it was i think i i don't even
think i've watched all of ace ventura
but i remember that
um all right not a bad question not a
bad question thank you brayden
better answer from mark than me well
done brayden what do you got jc
okay uh ryan c is interested in knowing
uh halloween was yesterday but for fun
what is your favorite childhood
halloween candy
and what do you think the favorite candy
of your favorite comic book character
would be
my favorite con my favorite halloween
candy is chris pratt
oh yeah we don't want to eat that snack
um i think my favorite halloween candy
hands down is reese's pieces
and prior to that the reese's peanut
butter cup but
reese once the reese's pieces was
invented then you could hold that [ __ ]
in your hand
and it wouldn't get all melty and
whatnot i think they had a
hard-coated shell that they stole from m
m's
well i would say yeah i would say
reese's pieces is my snack although that
came around in the 80s so if i had to go
further back
that's a big clark bar fan zagna yeah i
like them both and [ __ ]
um and who my favorite comic book
character
of course would be batman what would be
his favorite candy he looks like a black
licorice kind of guy
oh yeah there's no joy in his yeah you
know what i'm saying where he's like
you know they've had somebody giving
that poor [ __ ] a nice
twix in the wake of his parents death
everything might be different
whereas yeah my parents died but [ __ ]
you know the cookie
and the caramel and the chocolate
together
making me happy inside alfred i don't
know what to say i got a reason to live
and the problem is alfred is his
caretaker
so he's only got old man british candy
so that's what bruce was like that was
his idea of candy and whatnot
i think he's like i will eat all the
raisins that all the other kids get
because i like this bitter sweet
awful nugget he was the guy that like
well first off he wouldn't go
trick-or-treating because
beg for candy we could buy we're
billionaires
but if he did he would be the dude
eating the apple and [ __ ]
yeah first you'd be investigating
everyone's apples looking for razors and
stuff because that's how his mind works
my favorite candy was similarly reese's
peanut butter cups i never graduated
onto the pieces
i was all about the cups because you
just got more of it
um even the little minis you know i i'm
totally down for that
um i feel like um
spiderman would be all about the pixie
stix
i feel like he could just inhale the
sugar right through the mask
and that's that's like a tiny kid
vibrating at a very high frequency
who just needs straight [ __ ] sugar so
just
ripping it off puffing it up and then
hitting the [ __ ] webs
god remember i mean it's crazy like all
they did was like take sugar and paint
it purple
candy and you're like okay it
sure is are you sure this is candy it's
really more
uncooked candy raw ingredient of candy
like now go ahead eat that kid
yeah and i even better that was it was
the big dipper just a pouch of sugar
with the marshmallow
remember the liquor stick where it's
like they gave you a [ __ ] stick which
was also candy
put it into the sugar licked it off and
then eventually you could eat the stick
as well
good times yes how can i make sugar my
sugar eating vehicle
welcome to the big deal they really just
didn't care about children back then
no teeth diabetes
like give it to them give them
unadulterated [ __ ] sugar
let's create a new poison sugar high
fructose corn syrup
and we'll give them that let's see how
much this [ __ ] they'll eat
um jc give us our third and final
question
okay final question is from goddammit
russ uh
and they are looking for and i may be
opening a can of worms here but
we're on election eve so they're gonna
he wants to know
which view askew character would make
the best
president wow
no um i mean
after the last four years silent bob
because you wouldn't hear from the
president
[Laughter]
might be a welcome change for some um
let's see
oh god lance morrissette great president
there you go just um
yeah you know i got it easy we got a god
in my universe so
you did it go for a silly like well you
know randall might
[ __ ] that you make god the president
then people get maxed they're like you
need a chapter separation of church and
state
so then i maybe i can't be god i'll [ __ ]
it who's gonna fight god it's god
it's god there you go um seems an unfair
question for mark
no i'm thinking i'm thinking i'm i'm i'm
feeling like
maybe it's metatron
is it mertron or is it rock it's a rufus
i think it's rufus
yeah he's blizzard he's plus he's
a human being yeah he's wizard or
metatron or their spirit or
you know god this is a guy who is
actually a guy so he can relate
to the human condition he's seen some
[ __ ] he knows some [ __ ] he can relate to
the human condition but he's been
exposed to the glories and wonders
of the universe and can bring that
perspective to effective governance and
he's also a dude who's like you know
i knew a real leader i followed him uh
yeah name was jesus christ the same way
that like
biden constantly drops obama's name and
stuff
you know that rufus would be like and
did i mention my friend
jc i got the jc phone right here if it
ever gets dodgy i can always just put in
a call
you're a busy writer right now because
you've got a lot to do but remind me
when next we see each other to tell you
about it
like my remember i'm always like shut
the [ __ ] up stop giving away your
billion dollar
ideas i think i i think i had a billion
dollar idea
oh and you didn't give it away no i i'm
tempted to hear but i'm like i've
learned from [ __ ] you yeah
yeah i'm like i'm not going to
cinderella this [ __ ] so
stand while i fall i'm going to i'll
tell you when next we see you but i was
very proud of the idea i was like oh my
god this is
this would be [ __ ] fun and i bet you
this would make a lot of money and [ __ ]
excellent i can't wait to hear it and
then on twitter and tell everybody
because that is fair play i'll tell
everyone what you're up to
now we got collateral on each other nice
i learned that from the vow from the
nexium documentary
the tiniest non-sexiest cult but we
still have collections
next year's cult of two and then like
what kind of collateral they have each
on each other like nude pictures pornos
like really
dopey [ __ ] about like [ __ ] it's just
violating ndas honestly
that is silly um
that's that's all the questions we got
jc [ __ ] yeah that means we've done
duties our due diligence are you home jc
are you at the bar
i am home look at you man [ __ ] good
for you i put up a banner so you don't
see the mess in the background
i saw i saw the blue band my uh
my vote would be george carlin from
jersey girl
because it's george carlin oh my god
you're so right then we'd have him back
now my president could be alan rickman
then we'd have him back
outstanding yeah sure then we could have
her but
um now i think about it i've worked with
a lot of people that aren't with us
anymore and now i'm starting to wonder
if it was me
way to go buddy yeah really [ __ ] it
follows
and that is an entertainer uh because
right away i'm like
deaths that had nothing to do with me
might have something to do
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen did you enjoy this
election eve
uh edition of fat man beyond wasn't it
nice
uh to kick back and talk about the
things that really matter
um for a few hours
for a few hours we're going to turn you
back over to the real world you got to
go deal with it sooner or l
put the garbage out no vote tomorrow
is voting day yes if you haven't voted
already
and there's been ample time to either
mail in your ballot or drop it off or go
in early vote i
early voted last week um
and felt very good about it um
regardless of who you vote for
it is so important that you vote i
remember when i was a kid i remember my
dad
um used to always we used to get garbage
collection on tuesdays and fridays
and whether or not there was any garbage
he would always say take out the cans
and i would say dad we got like you know
a couple of [ __ ] toilet paper rolls
to put out there
and he would always say if you don't
take advantage of the service they will
no longer offer you the service um
and and i've always sort of taken that
with me especially with dealing with
civic responsibility
if you don't vote at some point they
will take away your right to vote
and if you've seen anything the last
you know six months or so just watching
the systemic and systematic
assault on voting rights and voting
capacity and voting polling places all
of it
this is what happens if you don't do the
thing that you are allowed to do
by right by law um so yes by all means
exercise your franchise as a citizen of
this country and vote
amen well said oh my god there would be
no
show tonight or any other night
definitely tonight
um we're enough because he was just like
we got to do a show we said
we're doing a show um without the man
who's not sitting next to me but is over
there uh give it up for mr mark
bernardin
my pleasure everybody there he's over
there there no there
there he is um and that ladies and
gentlemen
uh until next
uh oh it's happening it's starting to
ready
until next week uh when uh
hopefully we're all still here
for fat man beyond man i'm kevin smith
and i am mark bernard
uh tune in next week same fat well
actually some differing
fat time same fat channel though
spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith with the good of
all cree
ladies and gentlemen go vote yeah
you